>>> THE FBI IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF THREATS
AGAINST ITS PERSONNEL AND
OFFICES.
THEN LAST NIGHT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP SAID THIS.
>> THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAVE BECOME VICIOUS
MONSTERS CONTROLLED BY SKROUN
DRELS, MEDIA WHO TELL THEM WHAT
TO DO.
YOU PEOPLE RIGHT THERE AND WHEN
TO DO IT.
THEY TRY TO SILENCE ME AND MORE
TONIGHTLY THEY ARE TRYING TO
SILENCE YOU.
BUT WE WILL NOT BE SILENCED.
RIGHT?
>> HERE TO DISCUSS THAT IS
FORMER FBI SENIOR INTELLIGENCE
ADVISER PHIL MUD AND ANNUAL U.S.
JULIA KHEIM.
HE SAID A LOT THAT'S
IRRESPONSIBLE AND DANGEROUS.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> MAKES ME NERVOUS.
HOW DO YOU CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION WITH A FORMER
PRESIDENT VILIFY THE FBI.
REMEMBER PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
SERVICE HAVE TO GO HOME TO A
FAMILY INCLUDING CHILDREN AND
SAY IT'S A MIDTERM ELECTION
CYCLE WITH THOSE THAT LISTEN TO
THE PRESIDENT AND MAYBE MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY INTO AN ELECTION
CYCLE AND CONCEIVABLE THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE ONCE AGAIN PRESIDENT
BIDEN VERSUS PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF YOU HAVE PUBLIC INFORMATION
ABOUT THE HOME ADDRESS AND ON
MEDIA AS A FBI AGENT WHAT WOULD
YOU THINK?
IN CONTRAST TO THE DAYS I WAS IN
THE FBI AND CIA CHASING ISIS AND
AL QAEDA I WOULD BE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT GOING TO THE
HOME RESIDENCE THAN IN THE
PAPERS WITH STORIES ABOUT
CHASING AL QAEDA AND ISIS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO MAKE IT
CLEARER.
YOU HAVE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
PERSONAL SECURITY.
>> IT IS THAT BAD?
>> YEAH.
>> JULIA, IT IS REMINISCENT OF
THE CAPITOL ATTACK AND RIOTERS
HUNTING FOR VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
AND THEN LAST NIGHT HE CALLED
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AN ENEMY OF THE
STATE AND CALLING OFFICIALS
VICIOUS MONSTERS.
>> SO I LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH WHAT I CALL VIOLENT MA
MAGA-ISM.
IT IS THE REMAINING SUPPORTERS
WHO SHOW UP AT THE RALLYS THAT
ARE NOT IN FULL ATTENDANCE.
HE DOES NOT HAVE THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PRESENCE HE ONCE DID.
BUT I THINK THE TRUTH IS THAT
THIS IS -- THERE IS A SMALL PART
OF SUPPORTERS WHO DO SUPPORT
VIOLENCE AND SEEM RECEPTIVE TO
IT.
SO I LOOK AT THIS AS OTHER
VIOLENT MOVEMENTS.
I THINK THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS BIDEN'S FOCUS ON THE
SOUL OF THE NATION ASPECTS OF
THE SPEECH PROVIDE TO
REPUBLICANS AN OFFRAMP FROM WHAT
TRUMP HAS BECOME WHICH IS
SOMEONE WHO GOES AFTER THE FBI,
DOES NOT RESPECT THE PEACEFUL
TRANSITION OF POWER, SUGGESTS IF
NOT DIRECTS VIOLENCE.
I THINK THAT YOU SEE THE COUNTER
TO WHAT TRUMP USED TO DO AND I
THINK SOME OF THE METRICS ARE
PRETTY GOOD IN THE SENSE OF
VIEWING THIS AS DANGEROUS BUT
NOT GROWING AND IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER.
VIOLENT MOVEMENTS GROW ORR
FIZZLE.
I THINK A GOAL OF RESPONSIBLE
REPUBLICANS, BILL BARR AND
OTHERS THE OTHER DAY TO PUSH
BACK AGAINST THE VIOLENCE.
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
THIS STRAIN AT LEAST NOT AS
STRONG AS IT COULD BE.
>> HERE'S WHAT REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN CHENEY TWEETED
TODAY.
TRUMP ATTACKING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND YET AGAIN USING LANGUAGE TO
PROVOKE VIOLENCE.
ONLY ONE GROUP OF AMERICANS HAS
A CHANCE TO DIMINISH THIS
DANGER.
REPUBLICANS IF THEY FAIL TO STEP
UP THEY SHARE THE BLAME FOR ALL
THAT FOLLOWS.
PHIL, YOU WORKED ON
RADICALIZATION FOR YEARS.
WHAT WOULD BE THE AFFECT IF THEY
CONDEMNED THIS EXTREME RHETORIC?
GRAHAM SAID THERE WILL BE
RIOTING IN THE STREETS IF TRUMP
IS ARRESTED.
ISN'T IT BETTER TO TAMP DOWN
WHAT DONALD TRUMP WAS DOING LAST
NIGHT?
>> YEAH.
LET ME BE CLEAR HERE.
I'M NOT AS COMFORTABLE OR
CONFIDENT AS SHE IS BECAUSE I
THINK THE EVENT IS GOING TO THE
MIDTERM AND ELECTION CYCLE.
THE CHALLENGE IS NOT JUST A
PERCENTAGE OF THE ELECT RAT
THAT'S ANGRY BUT THE CHALLENGE
IS LEADERSHIP THAT VALIDATES
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THAT VIOLENCE
IS OKAY.
SO LET ME CUT TO THE CHASE.
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT IS
CANDIDATES.
YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THIS IS
BIZARRE.
CANDIDATES WILL BE ELECTED TO
CONGRESS THAT SAY ELECTIONS WERE
STOLEN AND QUESTION THE FBI,
THEY WILL HAVE THE MICROPHONES
AMPLIFIED ON TWITTER AS MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS AND GOING INTO AN
ELECTION 2024 THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THOSE LIKE THE
JANUARY 6 PEOPLE WHO MIGHT SAY
THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
I'M TYPICALLY A GLASS HALF FULL
GUY.
MORE AMERICANS SAY WE ARE ROBBED
AND ANGRY.
>> HOW DO YOU CHANGE THE MINDS?
IS THIS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE?
>> YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
THE FBI IS CLEARLY STATED THAT
BOTH THE VIOLENT STREAM OF THIS
MOVEMENT IS MOST DANGEROUS
THREAT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TO
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY AND
ELECTION WORKERS.
I AGREE WITH PHIL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS ENDS BUT I
KNOW HOW YOU FIGHT IT.
WHAT WE ARE STARTING TO SEE I
BELIEVE STARTING WITH THE
JANUARY 6 WITH THE FOCUS ON SORT
OF OFF RAMPING OF MANY
REPUBLICANS FROM THIS MOVEMENT
AND CONTINUING WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN TRYING TO REACH OUT TO SAY
THERE'S THE GOP AND THEN A LMTD
ALIGNING ITSELF AGAINST FBI
AGENTS AND THE RULE OF LAW,
AGAINST THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER AND THAT'S NOT YOU,
ESSENTIALLY.
WHETHER IT WORKS OR NOT I DON'T
KNOW.
TO THE EXTENT YOU FOCUS ON
VIOLENCE IS AN EXTENSION OF
POLITICS WHAT TRUMP IS
DELIVERING NOW THERE IS A WAY TO
COUNTER THAT AND IT BEGINS WITH
REPUBLICANS BUT IT BEGINS WITH
PEOPLE NOT VOTING FOR IT AND I
THINK THAT'S THE CASE THAT
CHENEY IS CLEARLY MAKING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WE APPRECIATE IT.